a mere 542 million years ago the Earth's
landscape was a barren wilderness 4
billion years after the planets creation
no animals lived on the land the most
developed organisms were simple animals
living in the oceans something
extraordinary was happening in the seas
over a period of 20 million years at the
beginning of a period called the
Cambrian an explosion of new animals
developed below the water's surface
these later gave rise to most of the
diversity of animal life that now exists
on earth but the cause of this sudden
burst of life which geologists call the
Cambrian explosion remains a mystery the
Cambrian explosion was really biologies
big bang things went from moving very
slowly along the sea floor without any
predation to suddenly all the different
type of ecologists that we find today
your life literally exploded what
triggered the camera explosion
we don't really know there are many
different possibilities different
hypotheses and we've got to remember
that cause and effect are often
difficult to disentangle so what
happened exactly to try to understand it
you need to look a little bit farther
back in the history of the earth to the
Ediacaran period which preceded the
Cambrian it was during this time that
the first large animals evolved but they
were shell less before the Cameron we go
into what's called the Ediacaran times
and this is an extraordinary interval
where we have the seafloor populated by
basically weird creatures and quite
frankly we're not quite sure whether
animals or something else entirely these
are organisms which seem to have mostly
survived on absorbing nutrients from the
seawater itself they may not have had
any gut some of them may be able to move
these creatures are principally soft
bodied that is a hello skeleton and then
they seem to more or less disappear as
the Cambrian explosion kicks off
after 45 million years of slow evolution
those weird creatures suddenly
disappeared to be replaced by those of
the Cambrian the first accounted arms
appeared 540 million years ago starfish
and sea urchins are their descendants
brachiopods followed after some ten
million years the trilobite the Cambrian
most iconic fossil joined the explosion
towards its end it showed up a few
million years later there are a number
of theories about what happened that
enabled these creatures to appear
there's a theory a hypothesis suggesting
that one of the factors that holding
back the evolution of animal is the
availability of oxygen photosynthesizers
things like cyanobacteria algae plants
make oxygen and organic carbon and once
the organic carbon is buried in the
sediment the oxygen is released in the
ocean and the atmosphere for animals to
use prior to the Cambrian explosion
oxygen levels may have been too low for
large active animals to survive but once
those levels increased larger animals
were able to survive and proliferate
then animals burst and a diversified in
many many different forms evidence to
support this theory of higher oxygen
levels is scarce but there may be a link
to a phenomenon called
snowball earth this was a long period of
recurrent ice ages when the glaciers
melted huge amount of rock were exposed
and eroded pouring nutrients into the
water that encouraged the growth of
photosynthetic algae which would have
caused oxygen levels to rise
but the last of the giant ice ages ended
around 90 million years before the
Cambrian things like oxygen levels which
are fairly clearly increasing during
this interval close to the camera
explosion must have been important but
oxygen was accumulating already much
much before then another theory for why
the Cambrian explosion occurred is that
minerals became increasingly available
in the oceans due to post glacial
erosion these could have been used for
the construction of shells but Cambrian
shells were made from a range of
materials this suggests that they were
the result of parallel evolution in
different animal lines
not a single innovation that means
something encouraged them to develop on
more than one occasion and shells are
costly to make it's unlikely mere
abundance of minerals would have been
enough could a transformative innovation
in the animals themselves be the
explanation one such innovation could be
bilateral symmetry which concentrates
nerves and sense organs at an animals
front and encourages the development of
an efficient gut with a mouth and an
anus
we are inventing nervous systems or
inventing eyes and other sensory systems
we're learning how to move fast how to
swim effectively so you have a whole
cascade of feedbacks and it's really
trying to pinpoint if you like the
trigger versus all the other
consequences which flowed from that
initial point the camera explosion
happens after a series of events in my
opinion first you need to have genetic
building blocks do you make an animal
you also need oxygen to support animals
to support animal metabolism but that
alone is not sufficient either you also
need a mechanism to drive the system
into a runaway situation you need to
make the system work very fast and a one
of the mechanism to drive the system to
a runaway situation is ecological
feedback ecological feedback in this
sense refers to the interaction between
predator and prey during the Cambrian
Predators evolved new mechanisms such as
vision to track down their lunch a good
part of what's happening in the camera
explosion must be the motor of
ecological change and one of the really
big important gear changes so to speak
to pursue that analogy is in the way in
which predators and prey interact part
of the explanation for the widespread
development of skeletons must be the
rise of predators and we see other
evidence in terms of mouth parts even
gut content sometimes you can see what
one animal swallowed and all these
things suggests that we are moving into
an ecology which is radically different
from anything ever before an integral
part of this is the evolution of nervous
systems and nervous systems of course
include ultimately brains and ultimately
of course when animals come onto land at
some times even in the oceans big brains
which start thinking oh
some believe the emergence of vision
during the Cambrian period caused the
rate of ecological change to accelerate
I believe that vision must have played a
significant role I think the fact that
that event coincides with the start of
the Cambrian explosion possibly could
indicate that vision was actually the
only thing that was required to trigger
the Cambrian explosion light today is
the most powerful stimulus of all and
vision is the most powerful sense when
that's unleashed on the world for the
first time it's going to create chaos
now the capability to sense light has
been there for a long time even some
bacteria has a way to sense light many
microorganisms have a way to sense light
but the very complex eyes they can very
precisely position the prey they can
view three dimensions and allow the
Predators to very effectively catch the
prey that's a very important part of the
ecological feedback that allows the
camera explosion to happen in a very
rapid rate now we have this pinpoint
accuracy a predator could spot a prey
and also because it's got its fast
swimming parts and hard part itself it
could get to that animal instantly and
tear it apart so that means now there's
huge selection pressures on all those
soft bodies animals to evolve defenses
against this which means really hard
parts it means shields and spines and
also hard swimming parts to swim away
itself but not everyone agrees now is
absolutely no doubt that eyes did evolve
as part of the Cameron explosion my
reservation with it is that eyes come in
all sorts of shapes and forms and
primitive eyes are really until more
than what we call ice spots they're
sensitive really sort of shades of grey
and white and no more than that and
that's quite sufficient for the great
majority of animals they don't actually
make an image on their eye whereas I
think one of the dangers if I may say so
was seen evolution through our eyes
we have fantastically well adapted eyes
which are the product of millions of
years of evolution and there's little
doubt that those really sophisticated
eyes only evolved a bit later there is
one other possibility the disappearance
of the Ediacaran creatures may be the
cause not the consequence of the
Cambrian explosion the explosion
resembles the recovery from a mass
extinction signs of a catastrophe 542
million years ago could easily have
vanished by now but that doesn't mean
one didn't happen
perhaps the bilateral ancestors of
today's animals were simply hiding in
the shadows of the Ediacaran world until
opportunity knocked whatever actually
did happen though they took that
opportunity with momentous consequences
for the future humans are direct
descendants of the Cambrian explosion
we have primitive fish from deposits
such as a burgess shale in Canada which
we can really say are our ancestors from
the human point of view the true
significance of the Cambrian explosion
is that Homo sapiens wouldn't be here if
it hadn't happened